[Music]
hello i'm danielle brooks and i play
leota atabayo on peacemaker neuro huh
yeah leota is a newcomer to the world of
superheroes and metahumans so i danielle
i'm going to try to dive into some of
the wildest vintage comic books and see
if i can figure out what the hell is
going on with them
so the first comic is detective comics
definitely this is pride month robin is
just confused he didn't know that man
was coming out i definitely think batman
should stick with the pink he does
wonders for his skin tone now we are
diving into the
flash did you see what i did there i'm
gonna take a wild guess here and say or
maybe they role-playing she gets excited
by being like you're not my husband you
are my husband oh my gosh it's a
stranger in my bed i think that's where
this is really going
now we are going to superman's lowest
lane
lois is getting it in with aquaman
batman and green arrow and that's okay
women to liberate yourself if you're a
single woman you have every right to
live your best life i'm guessing lois is
in her 20s watch peacemaker by
subscribing to hbo max don't do anything
stupid no problem i'll ask the questions
you're definitely going to be chill
[ __ ] chill dude jesus relax
hey no
maybe i should work with the man who
came up with these stories
call me